ma mère
avant
mais
oui
vous l'avez deviné c'est du rock qu'il
s'agit du rock and roll comme l'appelle
est encore ceux qui ne le pensent pas
pour ses fidèles le lieu de cette
religion nouvelle un nom pour vous
encore barbare johnny hallyday vous êtes
très jeune je vois je 18 ans vous avez
18 ans vous avez vous appelé à l'idc
d'autres non les desmans veut nous
laisser votre nom vous êtes français
c'est comme ceux de l'humanité
l'idée ce procès parce que de vacances
holiday à l idée ça me paraissait être
un nom choisi une lettre comme we have
air n'est pas passé loin tout même quand
il chante les corps des spectateurs se
tordent dans la salle comme sous le feu
de mille soleils
parfois il arrive même qu'à écouter trop
longtemps cette voix incandescente
sensible vraiment acquis gay et qu'il
fallait éteindre le feu
à grands coups pèlerine mais depuis ce
sinistre mémorable le pyromane à l'idée
s'est rangé dans les chefs vous assagir
un peu ou pas de me choisir mes deux de
toujours à la mode est toujours dans le
coup vous chantez en smoking mais ont
continué néanmoins vous rouler par terre
par exemple c'est pareil pas
incompatible faut c'est à dire que je
chante toujours de rock et je j'agis
toujours comme l'europe c'est à dire que
je chauffe avec le public mais vous
pensez que ça me faisait du bien de
croire ou non c'était cependant vrai nom
c'est le nom de mon cousin qui dansaient
qui s'appelait à l'idée et moi j'ai
voulu continuer avec leurs noms comme
cela avait toujours porté chance
seulement le truc de qu'ils ont un côté
sauvage et amérique comme ça moi ça
m'est égal enfants